being an author your dream job all I
ever wanted was to be an author the 1976
Guinness Book of World Records showed I
was six and it showed the youngest
author was four
Dorothy Straight and I cried and said I
can't be the youngest author like that's
how long I've wanted to do it
um it is my dream job being able
being an author and and selling my books
to companies and being traditionally
published was actually a total nightmare
being able to be an author who publishes
my own books and gets to kind of do it
for fun is my dream job absolutely
do you wish you could just be an author
and not have to run your own company
that's a good question no I love doing
all of it I it's not that I feel badly
for people who say that they write all
day but I think
that sounds kind of boring I love that I
get to write I get to make podcasts I
get to talk to clients I get to go do
speaking I I need the variety and I will
tell you I had years when I lived in New
York and I was just on contract writing
books for Harper Collins and my whole
life was sitting in my depressing studio
apartment with my two cats writing books
and to me I know that's a dream for some
people
not for me I I'm I approach writing like
a job I always think that when people
talk about writer's block I'm like oh
does the bricklayer walk wake up and go
I don't feel inspired I just don't think
I can lay a brick you know if you're a
writer you know have a self-respect to
do it every day and so when I was
writing books my deal with myself was I
will write three pages a day but I can't
write my three pages till I revise my
three pages from the day before
first time authors I don't recommend
revising as you go you should just get
your first draft out but that's how I
write books that's not fun I want to
have different things I don't it's very
isolating to write full time
well for someone who's an extrovert and
I know you said you're you're an
extrovert yeah that that does seem
difficult for those who are more
introverted and they you know it's
almost like they dread going to the
grocery store do you think that would be
a dream job or even for that type of
person it would still get depressing
I don't know I can't really get in
someone else's head but I will say the
people who tell me oh I just want to I
wish I could write full time they're
never the people who do I think
everything sounds better than it
actually is but I think I think
um
I think we also need experiences to have
things to write about if we're doing
non-fiction it's like you can't just
hole up and and have a whole world that
you can write about
that's a great point and so when you are
busy doing other things you're gonna
you're getting material yeah great
material if someone came to you and said
all I want to do is be an author that's
all I want to do what would you tell
them oh it happens to me every day
um I say great what's your business and
they say oh I don't have a business I
just want to be an author and then I'll
say why and they say well I really want
to help people with my story and I say
that's amazing go volunteer it's going
to be a lot it's a it's a much easier
way to help people if the average book
sells 300 copies and you could go out
and volunteer and help more than 300
people in a week that's going to be a
more fruitful use of your time
um I do not believe the profession of
author really exists today even the most
successful ones I mean I guess JK
Rowling Glennon Doyle Glennon Doyle's
doing podcasts doing speeches you know I
don't even think that's a job anymore
but for at least
99.999 percent of us it's not a viable
job I like I said when I was working on
that book I think I made a quarter of a
penny a day I think writers I think all
creatives should have the self-respect
to say I should be compensated
appropriately for what I'm doing I will
have people who say you know they maybe
don't say this to me but they sort of
think it's crass the way I talk about oh
you need to have a business and it's
like what I'm actually saying is you
should be paid for your work you
shouldn't be doing it for and begging
for pennies you should find a way to be
able to live a Wonderful Life while also
being creative
what if the flip side of the of the
would-be author comes to you and says I
want to be famous I don't care about
helping anybody I want my name on all
the lists
oh
um
you know I think to be
effective
and successful
as an author and to have it really mean
anything you kind of gotta have that
combination of having a really something
that really matters to you and a desire
to share it I don't think there's
anything wrong with wanting to be out
there sharing a message I think we live
in the most magical time we live in a
terrible time in so many ways and yet we
live in the most magical time in terms
of there are no Gatekeepers anymore
anybody can treat social media as their
own Magazine TV station radio station uh
publishing company and and I think so
many people look at it as this Albatross
oh I've got to steep keep putting
content out there what if it's just how
lucky are we that we can sort of be
creative put it out there whenever we
want and that there's no one there to
say no you're not good enough you're not
good enough so we're gonna pick her I I
think it's I think it's amazing so I
think that a lot of people I run into
sort of say well who am I to write a
book why should the world care about
what I have to say and it's like why not
you
why not
so is it almost good to have a little
bit of the of the
um bravado sort of uh you know just
Shameless self-promotion mixed with
some type of for lack of a better term
message absolutely I think I think that
what people need to remember is
self-promotion is not about you it's
like if if you have a message
um you know if you were covered from
something and most people who are
writing Memoirs or non-fiction books
have struggled with something and come
out on the other side and then they say
well I'm not that into self-promotion
and it's like if there's one person
whose life is going to be saved from
your book you owe it to them it's not
about you it's actually self-obsessed to
not share it because you think that you
know the the that's self-obsessed or
whatever it is
the average author sells how many copies
around 300.
and this is per year
total total okay yeah I mean there are
so many books being put out now and I
think people have their their numbers
are they're very confused about the
numbers when I and I'm the exact same
when I remember being in the like
elevator at Harper Collins and talking
about the first print run of party girl
and I remember saying yeah what's it
going to be like 68 000 you know to me
when you don't know you don't know how
many that means any book if you sell 10
000 copies of your book your book has
done very very very well
um you know if those 10 000 sales
happened in a week you're hitting all
the best seller lists so I think people
who even just sell 2 000 or 3 000 copies
of their books should feel really really
really good about it
you think people are reading less now or
actually more because they're using
Kindle and different things like that
it's it's not as far as I know the
statistics on reading haven't changed
it's the volume of books out there when
I published my first book in 2007
there's a fraction of what's available
today
why do most authors fail most authors
fail because they have completely
unrealistic ideas about what being an
author means they think they should be
able to write a book and have everybody
buy it and see their Brilliance that I'm
somebody who had to learn this the hard
way I did it six times failing to ask
myself who is this book for if I had
said that on my first book my career
would be so much different you need to
be able to say who is my book for and
what do I want them to do when they
finished reading it and if you can do
that you're gonna be in better shape
than 99.9 percent of authors out there
this is for non-fiction Fiction's a
little bit different but so so I always
with one of my books make your Mr Memoir
I pictured
one couple so it's two people I pictured
them the whole time every page would
they like this would this be too much
for them would this freak them out would
they get that and I highly recommend
that you know this marketing idea is the
riches are in the niches or if your book
is for everyone it's for No One the idea
with a book is you make it for the
smallest group of people possible
because what happens is that small group
the people in that small group read the
book and feel so seen and feel like they
have a book that's so specifically for
them that they go out and they start
recommending it to people now the main
reason we each pick books is somebody
recommended them unlike movies where
you're scrolling or whatever it is most
books are sold because somebody
recommended them so in other words
someone recommending your book means a
lot more than you recommending your book
so if you convert one Niche they become
your spokespeople they become your sales
people they go out and sell your book
for them so yeah so I thought about one
couple thinking you know if they exist
there's a lot of other people like them
you know a lot of people talk about
avatars and figure out you know what it
what kind of car does he drive and well
you know all these things I don't get I
just like to picture one person or a
very small group of people
was this like this this metaphorical
couple that you saw out somewhere where
you thought you know what I bet they
would be into this no it's actually I'll
tell you the story so it's this couple
that I knew from this Mastermind group
that I'm in and I and we had talked
about them hiring my company to do a
book for them and I thought what's the
book I could write that would convince
them that I was the right company to
hire so I write this book I get on Good
Morning America for it we bring in
hundreds of thousands of dollars in new
business they don't hire us because I
don't even think they read it I run into
them maybe a year later and I tell them
the story I go I wrote a book for you I
was thinking about you guys on every
page and they said that's hilarious and
we were it was at a gifting Suite so my
book was there and guess who I'm working
with now them they did hire us wow but
it really was it was really just an
exercise in
I mean my books I'm writing to help
build my business I want to be able to
be creative and the way I can be
creative and not have to worry about
money is if I have a business that it's
bringing people into so I always am
looking at it and I think anybody who
wants to be strategic and smart about it
looks at it like that what what do I
love to do how can I write a book that
will get people to hire me to do it
what does a writer need to know if they
don't want their book to fail
I think writers need to get very clear
about what success and failure means if
you're relying on the whims of the
universe it's like saying like how do I
not lose at the lotto like you can't
control what other people are going to
do I know I have had very
um successful book launches and
unsuccessful book launches and the
success didn't have to do with how many
books sold it had to do with how I went
into it if you go into a book Lodge and
you're thinking this has to happen and
these number of books have to sell and I
gotta get this review and like you're
setting yourself up for disappointment
if you go in and you sort of
um have have high expectations but keep
them loose and just decide you're going
to have fun with it it's going to be
amazing because if you allow whatever
the universe is going to bring better
things than you want are going to happen
but if you I had I had such miserable
book launches I remember talking to a
friend he said I never feel more sorry
for people than the week of their book
launch because everybody thinks you're
just having this incredible experience
but if you're traditionally published
you're just hearing from your publisher
usually it's not going very well you're
feeling like you got to do everything
you can and you can't control it so I
say you know when I compare how the
party girl launch went in 2007 when
Harper Collins released my book and how
it went in 2021 when I re-released it
myself it was a world of difference but
it was all my attitude